Alexander Wang: I don't
think there is any occasion
that all black isn't appropriate for.
Like, if there is, I don't go to it.
[Narrator] Today we're
talking to Alexander Wang
about styling all-black outfits.
We'll be talking about
the textures, proportions,
and accessories that keep
all-black fits interesting.
Black has been a cornerstone
of Alexander Wang's brand
and personal style.
So, Alex, why the black?
Wang: In my personal style,
I'd say that it's just,
it's easy, it's versatile.
Whether I'm going to work
or I'm going to the gym
or I'm going out right after work,
or, you know, I'm going to
another kind of meeting,
I think a black T-shirt
and a black pair of jeans
kind of really, essentially,
you can kind of win
in any situation with that.
Most situations.
I think in work as well, it
just creates this attitude,
immediate attitude, you know,
when I look at something
in black, and I think it's also
kind of like a blank slate.
When I do use color or
print, things like that,
there has to be a really
strong purpose and reason
and story why I'm using
fuchsia or turquoise.
We're not a colorful brand.
With black, it's kind of like the canvas.
It's just, you know,
it's kind of what really
wraps up the entire kind of emotionality
around what our brand stands for.
I think the best way to wear all black
is to really mix up your
textures and your proportions.
[Narrator] So what are textures,
and how do you pair them?
Wang: Texture.
I mean, I'm wearing black
jersey and black denim
and charcoal socks right now.
Today I did decide to wear
leopard pony-hair shoes.
Usually I'm wearing kind
of, like, black sneakers
or things like that.
It's not that I always feel like there has
to be an injection of something
of a print or something
humorous, or, you know,
unexpected in that kind
of outside of black,
but I do think it really
is about how you wear it.
I think a good pair of black jeans,
you know, are really important and kind of
a great, kind of universal piece to have.
[Narrator] And the
proportions, how about those?
Wang: I mean, obviously it applies
differently for each person.
I think it's really about knowing
your body type and kind of how to wear
certain kinds of archetypes or materials
that kind of exemplify your attitude
and your sensibility.
I tend to wear things a little bit looser,
a little bit more oversized,
'cause I do like things
that feel a little bit more offbeat,
a little bit more casual,
in every situation.
So even my blazers are
a bit more unstructured,
you know, my pants are
a little bit looser,
the crotch is a little bit more dropped.
I think it really depends
who the person is.
Sometimes black can feel very
strict, very buttoned-up,
you know, whether you're
wearing a tight black turtleneck
and kind of leggings,
and things like that,
which is also something that
we've done in the brand,
but kind of how you layer
it up and, you know,
throwing kind of a big sweater
or a big kind of, you know, cardigan
or a jacket over it really kind of changes
that attitude immediately.
I never like to dictate,
because I just don't think
there's any rules anymore.
You know, there really aren't.
You know, I might say that
right now and somebody might
come in in a skin-tight black
outfit, and I'd be like,
"Oh, [bleep], she looks great."
[Narrator] So how do you accessorize?
Wang: I'm really into gold.
I was a very, a silver person.
Now I'm very into gold as I get older.
So maybe that's it.
Evolution of myself.
Honestly, there's never been
an occasion where I felt like,
oh my gosh, you know, like,
is all black too much?
I didn't follow the
instructions today, by the way.
They told me specifically
not to wear black,
and of course just by
default I threw on black
and came here, and someone on my team
reminded me that I didn't listen.